starting off this hour is going to be
Rachel in Lexington Kentucky
hi Rachel how are you I'm fine how are
you better than I deserve what's up okay
I listen to your show on the radio and
also I listen to the little sound bites
before I called the collection agencies
I'm dealing with some medical bills I
just graduated from college and I'm
going to go to math get my master's
degree but right now I have $800 worth
of bills and I just ate my real dollars
I know that's not very much just making
sure I understood you okay I do have
student loans so yeah yeah so but I want
to deal with these because they're on my
credit report and so I titled two to one
collection agency and they have
collections in their name but so it was
550 for those and I offered them 275
which was half and they said we can't we
can only take the full amount and so I
said well my financial advisers Dave
brandy and that's not way he says you
know we can that you can take less and
they said no we just deal directly with
the company and if you don't pay it
doesn't go away and so I'm just like
confused I thought we could negotiate
yeah
well negotiate doesn't always mean you
just call them up and they give you
whatever you want right but they didn't
even have a counteroffer
they don't have to you could just say
well here's the situation I've got a lot
of bills and here's what you're going to
get you're either going to get a
settlement from me or you're going to
get nothing which one do you want well
we don't negotiate I understand but
you're going to get nothing is what
you're saying you want nothing so what
you want me to you want me to go and
give this money I've got to one of my
other bills because you're going to take
nothing if you knock something off we
can talk but if you don't knock
something off we're gone I'm gone oh we
don't negotiate okay I'm gone good day
let's hang up well that's what I did
doesn't let us sit there yeah and they
said where do you work and I went
missing cue
we you gotta be kidding when he don't do
you I sound stupid I was born at night
but not last night yeah ring really okay
well you just got it I got to be sassy
with them and mess with them because
they're definitely being sassy with you
okay aren't they
right yeah they're being jerks and so
just just had just mess with them but
you know and but you've got to have that
walkaway power punch them in the nose
and step back see if they bleed if they
don't then step aside and you may it may
take you a few months of messing with
them back and forth to get even a little
bit off the thing is this on a very very
small bill like that any bills that are
under $500 $500 or so they don't move a
lot because it's small enough most
people just write the check but where
you got a $5,000 bill that's where they
start talking about okay we get it you
can't pay it but you know I got to crime
a story and the story has to be true by
the way otherwise you're just lying and
I'm not suggesting you do that but I
just got out of college I'm getting
ready to go back into grad school I got
no freaking money and so this is all
I've got and if you want some money
today I can give you some money today if
you want to wait three or four months or
a year I can get you some money then
it's up to you do you want to just no
it's not going away we don't negotiate
well you're telling me you don't want
any money today's that want to make sure
mrs. so-and-so that that's really what
you're saying because that makes you an
idiot
do you really want to say that and you
know that's what you're saying in your
tone and the way you're delivering the
message and all that kind of thing and
you negotiate with them now here's the
other thing it's $800 if I were you I
just pay it yeah I mean it's not it's
not it's not a law that they have to
negotiate with you they negotiate with
you because they think you can't pay and
the only reason you should negotiate is
if you can't pay but if you legitimately
took out the medical services and you
legitimately have the money pay the bill
great well I agree it's just that I was
I don't and I was you know trying yeah
if you died and I don't and I know just
set the money aside in a savings account
and let the deal sit there let it sit
there and cook a little bit if it cooks
a little they tenderize okay all right
thanks for the call appreciate your
joining us hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button
to get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind